[Music]
welcome back to my 12 ding-dongs of
Christmas we're counting down the
biggest of the bares and bus dots we've
had on uncensored in
2023 when Disney announced it was to
replace it seven doors of magical
creatures the upcoming Snow White remake
I wanted to know if it was just another
case of off to woke we go I've always
use this show as a platform to stand up
for the little guys never before have I
meant that quite so literally as I do
tonight behind the scenes pictures from
Disney's liveaction remake of Snow White
with leite this weekend there appears to
be a sizable problem where are the
dwarves they're gone cancelled banished
and not this time by the wicked Queen
are they've bitten the poison apple of
diversity and inclusion which has turned
out to exclude them Disney's PC
reimagining of the legendary fairy tale
doesn't feature seven dwarves at all
instead it's seven magical creatures of
varying sizes shapes ethnicities and
genders well joining me is Dylan posel
who played Hornswoggle the leprechaun in
WWE between 2006 and 2016 and by the
podcaster and commentator James Bar the
people who it seems to me have really
suffered in all this are the six dwarf
actors who would have expected to have
roles in this remake in a massive
Hollywood Blockbuster who are now not
going to have that experience all the
money all the fame that may have come
with there what is your response to
that so it's not a progression at all to
me my issue with it is exactly what you
said there are actors dwarf actors that
live that that dream to be in a major
Motion Picture such as this Disney
remake and now because Peter
Dinklage said what he said last
year now it's taken away and it's taken
away because of quote unquote
progression and all that and that's it's
not it's not really it's not right
because these are roles made for actors
of my stature roles that aren't ever
really given I can't go out for the the
Harrison Ford or the George Clooney
roles because that's not for me these
dwarf roles are for people of my stature
and now it's taken
away I don't feel that's right the irony
is that they profess these progressives
to want to do this to protect you right
they protect dwarf actors from being you
know somehow smeared but you don't feel
that way at all
Peter Peter Dinklage spoke up about this
and that was my issue he had in the past
no issue cashing checks that were made
for dwarf roles like elf and all of that
yes he blew away the barriers when he
did his his roles that weren't NE
necessarily made for a dwarf but the elf
role was made for a dwarf that check
cleared just fine so now that he's gone
and done that the progression of dwarf
actors he's he it just doesn't it
doesn't sit right with me this guy who
is exactly what you said what what gave
him the voice for all of our
community a complete hypocrite let me
bring J me bring James back ingan is
agreeing with you I think you need to be
concerned I'll say that for the so
you're telling a dwarf after what he
should feel having hang on having
literally just lectured me about
speaking for someone in the dwarf
Community War Davis you now accuse a
dwarf actor not no that's not what I
said I said that if anyone if you're
siding with anyone you've got to worry
what I'd like to say actually is that I
kind of mostly agree with what you're
saying now you're sir that's just taking
a podt shot there by say it is
absolutely taking a PO shot but I do
agree with what you're saying I
completely agree with with your point of
view and I think that's really important
but I I can only speak from my
experience and as a gay man I know that
growing up I witnessed gay people being
villains in movies when I was seven
dwarves aren't villains and that I think
stereotypes are really important to what
stereotyp actually in the universe of
Snow White wouldn't it be better dwar I
don't feel
this this isn't a part of this about The
Stereotype right this is about roles
that were that were made for people such
of my sture that don't have the chance
to go out for other roles normally but
you James you want to stop Dyan getting
a role in a hollyood I'm not going to
get into an attack on a dwar you don't
want a dwarf actor to a role a dwarf
part listen a dwarf can play a dwarf
part but I think it's important to
change narratives that don't fit in
today's society and really it it might
be better if dwars just exist in normal
roles everywhere because they do exist
about the way dwarves were depicted in
Snow White have I missed something well
that listen I'm not here talk that's
what that's what I'm kind of wondering I
don't represent Disney but I'm just
saying I think I see their point of view
what's their point of view what was so
bad about the depiction of the why are
you so upset about a movie changing with
the times and moving forward honestly
with great there is real news we could
be discussing no but this is real news
if you're a dwarf actor who are now out
of work because of virtue signaling
idiots who think that everything has to
be Rewritten to be inclusive in it's at
all no you're using Dylan as a cheap
shot to attack a woki that's I don't
think Dylan feels I'm using him as a
cheap shot and what I would say about
the woki thing is this I have spent the
last year listening to people tell me
only gay actors should play gay Parts
only Welsh actors of Michael Sheen
should play Welsh characters and so on
and so on and so but the moment we have
dwarf roles which are the most famous
dwarf roles in Hollywood history then
the only people apparently you can't
play them are dwarf actors and I see
there hypocrisy it has not changed it
was a cartoon those weren't actually
dwarfs in the movie they were drawn okay
so firstly they were drawn as dwarfs no
that is a story dwars dwars well they
should be called they shouldn't be
called dwars no they should be called
people with what's wrong with being dwar
but that's not the correct that's the
story D apparently you're not allowed to
call apparently Dylan you're not allowed
to call yourself dwarves apparently
I would love to hear what should I call
myself sir I think you should call
yourself whatever you feel comfortable
with but as a person he call himself a
dwarf that's that's aw good for you I'm
happy so now but now sir let me let me
let me pause that so we it it shouldn't
be called Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs it I want to get canel because I
think your point of view is more
important than mine right now but what
I'm annoyed about is PE trying to take a
cheap shot at someone that believes in
society moving forward I'm actually I'm
actually exposing the hypocrisy of the
woke mentality of only gay people can
play gay Parts only trans actors can
play trans parts and so on and so on and
so on to the to the point Snow White the
Seven Dwarves has to be cancelled
because you're not allowed to have dwarf
you should be happy Pierce because it
means that now you can play your dream
role of grumpy I would love to play
grumpy I loved all the dwarves in that
movie they were great I don't speak for
the whole dwarf culture and and
Community but this is lit Dogan speaks
to the entire got to leave it there all
of you thank you D for joining me and
James that's helpful thank you for
joining me because you came on and you
beautifully highlighted
the hypocrisy of your culture
absolutely in June just have all
protesters made headlines from
interruped the LA's test match which I
happen to be at of a Time unacceptable
especially ruining my fund so I knocked
them for six with the help of a criting
legend joining me now as environmental
campaigner donica mcarthy justop Royal
spokesperson uh Chloe NR and the former
England uh test Cricket Legend Sir
Jeffrey boyot so welcome to all of you
well let me start with Chloe Chloe NRE
uh
Chloe even the people who were funding
you even the millionaires behind a lot
of this stuff they're sick of it they're
sick of the performative stuff the
attention seeking the wrecking of stuff
that other people enjoy they recognize
none of it is turning anyone's opinion
uh they're as sick of it as I am why do
you all keep doing this why is it that a
bunch of really ordinary
community-minded uh law-abiding people
are taking this kind of action and the
answer is because we're in a climate
emergency and our government is not
taking it seriously this action at Lords
today isn't the biggest climate story of
the day the biggest climate story of the
day is the fact that the government's
own climate change committee which is
headed by by the conservative peer Lord
Deon has found that the government's Net
Zero strategy is failing on every single
one of its targets that means they're
not keeping us safe now and they are not
in theut you know what come on shows
like this and debate that I'll invite
you on to have a proper debate about
that invite us on my message we come on
anytime reality is the only way we get
on is by doing these no it's not the
only way you get on that's a complete
myth there have been regular debates on
shows like mine that don't involve a
reaction to the kind of ridiculous
nonsense we saw today the truth is
you've become a group of wreckords you
just like wrecking things for the sake
of wrecking nobody is coming along to
your cause because of these stupid
stunts we all think you're a bunch of
pural spoiled brats who are just going
out of their way to cause other people
inconvenience and ruin their fun that is
the reality you might well have serious
hang on let me finish you might well
hang you might well have a serious point
to make or many serious points to make I
might well agree with some of those
points I probably do but you know what
the more of these things you do are
things that I enjoy and my friends enjoy
and my family enjoys and other people
with their friends and families enjoy
the more families that you stop and
getting to work or getting their kids to
school for important exams or getting to
funerals or whatever it may be the more
you do that the more we hate you and the
more we don't want to have anything to
do with you or give you a plat form to
talk about the stuff that actually is
more important as you rightly say why
don't you just stop the stupid stunts
stop wrecking people lives this won't
stay in the news and it won't stay in
the conversation and perhaps what we're
doing by interrupting the things that
you need to do that are important to you
that you love is we're making you think
about everything that we you're making
me think you're a bunch of more Lord
Debon said today note de said you're not
making me think about your cause nobody
at laws today think you know this is
about climate change we saw the orange
powder the whole crowd started booing
fortunately England's working keeper
Johnny be let talk uh actually no I'm
gonna cut you off I'm go I'm GNA go to
to Jeffrey boycut Jeffrey um you're a
cricet legend you I remember back in the
70s a pitch being dug up at headingly uh
which wrecked a test match in a
different kind of protest but this this
series of attacks on stuff that most
Britains just like what it the snooker
the cricket the Chelsea flower show what
do you make of it does it convince you
that you should take this kind of thing
seriously no I watched it today and I
just started laughing I thought the
England players did well and with the
Aussie batsman they made a barrier at
one end for one of them so they couldn't
get through and then the uh the staff
came on and grabbed him on Rugby tackled
him Johnny picked up the other one and
the orange powder it actually went on
the ground about 8 or 9 10 yards away
from the pitch so it didn't do any
damage whatsoever and I just laughed I
thought it was foolish I I just thought
it was stupid everyone now Associates
just stop oil with just a bunch of
morons wrecking people's lives that's
what people like you call them I would
actually call them Heroes because what's
heroic about running on
aing thing was said about the rugby
protest and the apar era let's what
let's remember what's happening with the
Cricket World you talk about the
sacredness of the sport and the
sacredness of the cricket pitch look at
the cricketing world Caribbean destroyed
by hurricanes Pakistan destroyed by
floods India extreme heat what those
cricketers are doing today is taking the
S on the wrong side they're fting on the
wrong the cricketers should have should
have stood up and Stood Beside the stff
St o ridiculous no funding for new
fossil fuel this is where you lose me
this is there's a serious debate to be
had about what's been going on in all
those countries I get it I believe
climate change is real I believe it's
dangerous I believe in the core
inherent essence of your protest right I
just hate the methodology and so I can
tell you do 99% of this country they
can't stand it and I can say back to you
I've been involved in this for 30 years
I spent 10 years local campaigning 10
years in politics Deputy chair of
liberal Democrat I've done Campa
campaigning I've done petitions I've
done marches and now you're reduced to
chucking paint around no I haven't
chucked paint around but you're
supporting them I'm actually suppor
because nothing else has worked so
please tell me we've tried politics
actually you say nothing else has work F
can work the UK has one of the best
records in the world in measures to
combat climate change that is an
irrefutable fact and If you deny that
you are actually denying the very thing
that you accuse other people to do which
is reality there are two things Britain
is better than the world in in in in
most countries in reducing the carbon
emissions of our electricity system
everything else were disastrous and the
most important thing about Britain which
links to today's project n JP Morgan
Bank is we're one of the largest funders
of new fossil fuels glob why okay as a
broad brushstroke it is undeniable that
the UK is doing more than most countries
in the world who are ACC of the
prosperous countries is doing more to
combat climate change than most others
that is a fact what I'm agreeing with
you is that we're doing more on our
electricity our own 1% but the city of
London and our old corporations are
funding 50 of global here's my advice so
we have to protest here's my advice no
you don't it's a center of the come on
show come on shows like this and make
your arguments and don't go and wreck
people's can you please invite us on
with Morgan and barle and shell let me
go to the final word to to Jeffrey
boycott if you're still there Jeffrey um
I want to lighten the load Jeffrey and
just ask you are we going to win the
ashes
no
[Music]
more sporting drama at number four this
time involving the beautiful game are
the ships on the famous crest of
Manchester 2 football and Giants racist
lead us to say it all kicked
off well joining me now as the author
and playright Bonnie Greer talk to the
contributor and lawyer Paul rone Adrien
and the podcast host of the cross the
pond hotep Jesus well welcome to all of
you um all right Paula let's start with
you because I know what you're about to
say is going to make me infuriated and
it's going to be utterly insufferable
excellent uh these are two quests that
carry images of sailboats yes it's got
nothing to do with slavery or
racism if that's your opinion then
you're entitled to have it it's a fact
it turns out the historians say
Manchester didn't adopt ships as an
emblem until
18425 35 years after the abolition of
slavery so they would have had nothing
to do with and how do we know that we
don't know that so what you are doing is
you are taking one understanding of a
situation so you're believing the
historians it's not what I believe Pier
let's be clear about this we're having a
debate and that's what is important
about should be looking pictures little
pictures of of ships on a footballer
Crest bad who cares got nothing to do
with it well clearly I'm sure the
players at Manchester City and
Manchester United those who Advocate uh
you know show racism the red card no
here's what's going to happen they will
care about here's what's going to happen
the guardian which has just been caught
with its racism trousers down right
because it turned out they were founded
by a bunch of slave owners right so
they're the last people on Earth to be
lecturing about this is that right
aren't they aren't they the right people
no they're not they're not because I
found I found their Hing I found their H
ringing over that utterly ridiculous
I'll tell you why well they've
apologized every single family in
Britain if you go back far enough you'll
have people in their past hundreds of
years ago who employed slaves almost
certainly and therefore and therefore we
know that was wrong then why should
everybody today who had nothing to do
with it terrible spend their entire time
apologizing for it it's about education
yes first of all just education and the
second thing it's about and you know
this we always rewrite history we wrote
We rewrote World War II because we found
out about B we didn't a person who grew
up in the 50s would have a different
World War II than a kid now because we
found out about Bletchley so we are
getting more intelligent and that's one
thing that's happening and
mean hang on hang on and and the other
thing the the United Kingdom was
actually on the side of the
Confederacy during the Civil War and in
fact was going to send a ship to the
Confederacy to fight for it when it was
St
by lincol and paid an Indemnity to
United States who is going to pay me yes
and my family reparations for what the
Vikings did to us well I think you
should seek it out who's going tol seek
it out literally so we go back every
Invasion every bad what it is the
ideal the ideology of denial denying
anything happens so then let's deal with
it what I'm saying is once you start
this woke Rampage is no end a bit like
the statues of historical figures
they're all guess what hang on let me
fin ladies give me a moment all
historical figures are flawed you can
find flaws in Mandela in Gandhi and
Churchill it's why they had to be
boarded up their statues at Parliament
Square so the mob didn't attack them but
if we take this route everything all the
time we have to be apologizing paying
for why WR what's wrong with an apology
nothing is wrong with that if you very
sorry the hundreds of years ago people
it's not anything to do with hundreds of
years we acknowledge it we always do
that that is what history why should
footballers have to remove crests that
contain images of ships which according
to many historians were adopted as an
emblem 35 years after slavery was
abolished well it was abolished but it
wasn't over okay and that's all are All
Ships racist no we don't know that but
we need to inv sh racist investigate it
why not what's wrong with that All Ships
could be racist why you going make
generalization about see ridiculous
that's that's ridiculous point you are I
think I think the Irish should talk to
the
Norwegians I think the Irish should talk
also the Italians and the
Romans what's going to happen about the
Romans I need reparations for I think
the Irish should talk to the Iceland
it's
preposterous not Preposterous it's good
diog you know what it is here's what it
is it's exhausting well that's different
honestly W mentality so exhausting I
feel myself literally getting tired
ased try being a black fale am sure
being a black F can be wonderful I can
have chall we don't need to have this
kind of walking around being no better R
talking um women are going to see the
world frankly different from men women
are very emotional so of course they're
going to be worried about you know
what's on the badge and all this stuff
when we look at the UK right the UK has
about four million Starving Children
what is this right now and that doubled
since the past two years my brother
Hotel do you think that children that
are hungry care about some badges they
can't eat football badges the hotel you
know what leftism does is they try to
sidestep the real dilemas and worry
about all of these Frills on the outside
on the exterior let me apart from saying
that you've made two really good friends
here with your women get to emotion from
the south side of
Chicago and I'll let you three deal with
that after the
[Music]
show into the top three now in 2023 so
me face off against some old foes and a
few new ones as
well you campaign bio claimed you ran a
foundation called friends of pets United
in New York and New Jersey that saved 2
and a half thousand dogs and cats over a
5year period that true that's true um
but I wasn't alone in in the operation
uh I had there was a multitude of people
we were all volunteers I was the
operator I was one of the I think we
were seven Founders if I'm not mistaken
between New York and New Jersey uh my
advocacy in in animal uh welfare and
animal rights is that stems from my
childhood I've always very compassionate
towards animals I own four dogs at home
they're all rescues to to one sword I
call it the home of Misfits they're all
unwanted three legs heart murmur you
know the issues like that and um now
everybody is after all the revelations
about the organization I wasn't in
charge of any of the the weird thing is
there were no social media accounts for
it no tax those were all deleted well
there were no the ones anyone could find
no tax records no evidence of the
charity being registered in either New
York or New Jersey they did run one
fundraiser with the rescue group in New
Jersey in 2017 for which you charged a
$50 entry fee but the group which staged
the event said it never received any
funds and I can attest that that is not
true the funds all ran through through
the group and the the post of the of the
facility was who was in charge of all of
our of our filings so this came to a
surprise as much what happened to the
tax records to the social media I I
wasn't in charge of any of that it was
never set up as a even well I I wouldn't
know that I was the operator I was the
guy putting cats out of the streets into
my car taking them to
get in charge that I when you say you're
the operator of this of this foundation
and there's literally no record of any
of it it doesn't doesn't lend much
credibility to your operational skills
like like I said I wasn't part of the
administrative part of the group we were
seven people everybody had their own
tasks my task was George go pick up this
dog go pick up this cat there's that was
my task go go deliver this adoption and
that that was my involvement with the
organization and I quite frankly did it
well I still get a lot of message
supports from people who adopted from
from from us that during the the period
of time I was involved who would have
all the records I I don't know who would
have all the records one of the seven
people that you work with uh I would
assume somebody has a
records you in
jail what was that like Romanian jail is
not not English jail me describe it what
was the cell like I have to be careful
what I say because I don't want to
insult the Romanian justice system which
I'm still beholden to however it's
exactly as bad as people would expect it
to be luckily it was in the winter so
the Cockroaches were not too
bad it was also during Ramadan so I
didn't have to eat so much which was
helpful because of the situation I think
the most stressful thing about it is I
had no idea how long I was going to be
in there for I was dragged from my house
I was given papers in Romanian I didn't
know why I was there I found out why I
was there and it was garbage I couldn't
seem to get out I could have been held
for years it's very stressful and uh the
best thing you can do is turn to God and
and train as hard as possible I did
thousands of push-ups a day every s were
you in solitary this in this period
three months I no I wasn't in solitary
the entire month the entire time
sometime I was by myself sometimes I was
with other guys and sometimes I was with
my brother so when you were on your
own were they keeping you in there for
24 hours a day were you allowed out no I
wasn't allowed out there was no yard
time it was 24 hours a day locked in a
single room probably
three or four steps large and you do
nothing but stare at the wall and you
think how many days did you do that for
on your own 11 12 I mean that's a
pretty Grim scenario for for anyone
life's Grim do you get emotional did you
shed tears in your cell I'm an emotional
man I think I think men are hyper
emotional we just have to control it I
was extremely busy inside of my jail
cell I had lots of push-ups to do I was
very concerned the people on the outside
I was trying my best to get
out it's difficult for me to answer the
question because it was a interesting
frame of mind I knew that God was
watching and I had to perform it's very
difficult for me to go through life
saying I'm the top G I'm this I'm that
and speak about mental resilience and
mental toughness and then the second I'm
thrown inside of a solitary confinement
cell cower out I'm not that person some
there's some other people who talk about
mental toughness and want to give advice
and when bad things happen to them they
end up addicted to prescription drugs
I'm not a coward I'm not a liar you
cried there were tears that ran down my
face but I did not cry I mean that's
crying let me ask you about the lover
boy method so the suggestion is that you
and your brother and others uh but you
let's talk about you that you deploy the
lover boy method where you would make
women fall in love with you you would
then persuade them to do a webcam webcam
stuff right Tik Tok okay but wait it's
called it webcam stuff right no it's not
call it that the indictment is about Tik
Tok
okay what would you make the women do or
what would they do with you I don't make
anybody do anything in fact let's talk
about the lover boy method so it's very
interesting let's Imagine The Matrix is
pissed off with a said individual who's
telling too much truth and everybody is
listening to him and they decide they're
going to attack him with sexual assault
claims they say ah he's making women do
well we found conversations where he
gave advice on how to go viral on Tik
Tok he's making women do Tik Tok but he
isn't being horrible to them he's not
hitting them he's not being mean to them
so what can we do let's use the lover
boy method if I was abusive and mean
they wouldn't say lover boy method you
you know what lover boy method means
being nice he was nice and polite and
kind and they really liked him as a
person and he told them how to do T
that's not what the boy of course it is
Andrew that's not what the lover boy
method is absolutely it is the lover boy
method is where perpetrators woo victims
or the prospect of a loving relationship
until they can be forced into abusive
situations or a form of slavery this is
garage that's actually what it means the
lover boy method is being nice to people
so that you work together effectively
what they're trying to say here I was
nice to girls who asked me for Tik Tok
advice and they sang It's The Lover Boy
method I didn't beat them into doing Tik
Tok I didn't force them I didn't
threaten them in fact I was like yeah
you're very pretty you can be pretty F
was there any element of coercion How
can there be an ele what does that even
mean let's be professionals here what
does that even mean what do you think
coercion means I was coerced into this
interview you came along to me and said
you weren't coerced into this intervie
yes I was or don't tell me the bullying
MSM said Andrew you've got to do an
interview and I'm going to fly all the
way to Romania to do it do that you used
the lover boy method you said boy me y
Andrew this is going to be a very
interesting interview we had a good one
last time you're a nice guy we have some
interesting conversations I'm going to
come along we're going to make some
money from this interview money will be
made for both sides you boyed me you
stole the profit just to be clear I've
had no conversation with you about this
interview and the conversations I've had
with your intermediary were very
professional and I said I would like to
an interview were you nice of I'm always
nice lover boy you can't believe you use
niceness to lover boy me because this is
a profitable Enterprise and I was
coarsed here I make no pretense that I'm
into I've come all the way from London
to remaining to interview you because
yes I want to do it on my show and that
will clearly benefit me and my show am I
a full grown consenting adult who
decided to do the idea but you're not
being coerced into do am I a full grown
consenting adult who decided to do this
show yes okay so I wasn't coerced
correct well what's that got to do with
what I've asked you because you were
nice to me and you're saying that I
wasn't nice to you I didn't even talk to
you being nice is the lover boy method
and that adults no responsibility and
nice to someone they become your slave I
wasn't nice to you and I didn't call you
a nice guy I feel lover boy I feel L I'm
sorry well I'm sorry it's
fine has one of the lessons that you've
learned from Miss lawsuit with the Sandy
Hook families has one of the lessons
been that actually truth matters have
you learned that do you believe now that
you need to focus on saying things which
are true because consequences can be
very
serious you keep trying to act like it
was a big part of what I've covered or
that I made mistakes on purpose the
whole currency I operate in is in truth
and we're accurate 95% of the time I've
made big mistakes and when I make
mistakes we absolutely admit to it I
think you've done that yourself sometime
so I'll you know here's the deal maybe
in 10 years you're still alive I'm alive
I'm back on you'll say will you
apologize now I apologize if I cause any
pain I've already done it it only makes
them more rabid and attack more and
misrepresent I went on my show during
the the trial and said I love you I
think you're real I'm so sorry for your
child they went on the stand and said I
attacked him that day that's all on
record and so the problem is the reason
the problem isal movement hundreds of
millions of dollars off their dead kids
the problem is you did make millions of
dollars from their dead kids so mine
Albright kills 500,000 says
she Jones questions of mass shooting I
get it I'm the worst guy in the world
whole dying corporate media is good Alex
Jones is bad but here's the thing
wars.com lives people can come to my
show every day 11:00 a.m. Central and
they can hear what I'm actually saying
Piers versus what you're trying to put
in my mouth I see all I'm putting into
your mouth are things that have come out
of your
mouth no you don't have footage of me
saying go harass them at their houses
you I cover the S I covered the Sandy
Hood you don't have any of that
you all I know is for all your posturing
the truth infowars.com when those poor
families let the most excruciating lives
you took a massive amount of fuel and
you P
the about the bottom line you
deliberately spun a pack of designed to
make thees of
sand wor about the that I'm afraid all
your
sh is utterly contempt and we both
you're going get our first amendment and
I'm glad you had to move back to England
to live under your Islamic takeover and
when they're arresting people for being
against
transgenderism you want freedom the
pl welcome back to my 12 ding-dongs of
Christmas we're counting down the
biggest of the bares and bus dots we've
had on uncensored in
2023 well they had to be on our
countdown didn't they Harry and Megan
the juk and Duchess of Netflix they
couldn't even Top This there are spare
winners for
2023 well for 2 and a half years there's
been frenzy speculation about how who
these supposedly racist Royals are just
about every single member of the royal
household has been implicated in the
rumors at some point and that surely
isn't fair is it just guilt by
Collective
Association especially if you believe as
I do as I've always said that the claims
in my opinion are completely and utterly
baseless that specul reach fever pitch
again this week because of his weasly
lick spittle omed scobby he's the client
journalist of the susex he's always the
first to publish their Soviet Style
official statements and defend their
indefensible deeds he's like that guy
comical alley do you remember him who
fronted up for Saddam Hussein in the
Iraq War and would literally say we've
got him on the run as the American how
it say we're coming over his head well
mean marle famously denied briefing
scobby for his last book Finding freedom
but then she was forced a few months
after it came out to apologize in court
and admit that actually she had she
briefed one of her aids to go and tell
scobby all the L all the laundry so when
it emerg that the leg's book contained
new details on those race accusations
well let's just say I've made my own
assumptions about where scobby could
have got that information from because
it wasn't King
Charles so that only the other person on
the end of that correspondence that's
Megan Markle or maybe Harry her husband
or maybe one of their mutual friends
that scobby keeps boasting he has scobby
says he knew the names of the accused
Royals but couldn't use them for legal
reasons that's in the English version of
his book then as everybody now knows the
names suddenly appeared in a Dutch
translation of the book and by appear I
mean they were sent to journalists who
couldn't believe what they were reading
they went into bookstores where people
could buy it well last night I decided
this was all ridiculous and it was time
to name the two roles implicated in
those racism claims they are as I said
last night King Charles Prince Charles
as he was then and Katherine Princess of
Wales I did that for several reasons
first the speculation was once again
raging out of control Tess Dunlop you've
been seething away quietly to my left I
can see you simmering so simmer away
you a pull me peers occasionally I think
no he's found the light he's seen the
light he's no longer crashing on about
Harry and then this appalling di tribe
we've just had to sit through you
claiming you lying there suggesting that
you're putting their names out
effectively to save the monarchy you put
their names out for clicks you're no
better than omed scobby in fact you're
worse you call him a little spittle
you're a great big go of fleem that's
just just landed on the Royal doormat I
don't know how you slept last night I
struggled to sleep thinking about what
You' done I really can't and yes I did I
didn't know that suggest stop the
performative crap honestly it's
performative crap no let's just hold on
to calm down have a civilized
conversation idea you didn't sleep over
this you don't even know these people I
was no I was properly angry by your
hypocrisy and then the hpoc because you
spend day in day out your pro monarchy
the wonderful Queen wonderful Charles
and then you go and do Kate and Charles
right in it when one's at 28 yes you did
wait a minute no no no I'll tell you who
did that omed scobby because these names
appeared in a draft of his book which
was published in the Netherlands they
were under the line to Netherlands was
tit tatt how do you know that Megan's
rumors were baseless how do you know
what she accused family any of it but
where's the evidence that it was
baseless
well obviously it's very difficult when
the two are the chief witness they
couldn't even decide on Oprah Winfrey
what year these supposed conversations
that happened or how many there were
right they couldn't decide what year
doesn't mean it didn't happen you take
notes and write in your diary nothing
happened really let me get a Dicky I
will take issue with you naming
yesterday and I made that point this
morning um you are a bit of a law onto
yourself I didn't take the law onto
myself I actually applied a letter of
the law this information published in
the Netherlands Dutch people were free
to read it and I took a view it was
ridiculous the British people couldn't
be aware of this information right Paula
thank you wow okay so you're going to be
shocked at this but I actually agree
with you that you named that you
identified them yesterday and let me
explain to you why because everybody in
the Royal Circle knew who it was all the
Royal journalists knew who it was I've
spoken to people who knew who it was the
fact that they've been named did didn't
come as a surprise to me because it's
fairly common knowledge among
journalists I actually don't think many
journalists knew about Princess of Wales
I think they thought it was another
member of the royal family but you
accept well I was actually surprised but
I was not surprised that again it made
it even more to me obvious that this is
all complete bull crap exactly and
that's where you and I actually agree on
this because the the the fact that it
was they they were named in the
Netherlands is almost neither here nor
there the fact is there are people here
who knew and you're right the British
people did have a right to know who it
was and now we know who it is what's
going to happen next well surely action
needs to be taken and here's where I am
disappointed with you I'm disappointed
with you because we had a monologue of
you berating and throwing disdain at uh
at Megan at Harry at Omid talking as if
you have spoken to King Charles talking
as if you have spoken um to Kate spoken
as if you have spoken to Camila but you
haven't and so if you haven't everything
that you have said is based on
assumption and I think you did accept
and I think you did accept actually and
and everyone resp no no because you
actually used the word assumptions in
what you were saying you are also making
very D you are also making very
dangerous assumptions and what you have
done this evening is you have set
anybody back who is suffering from
racism
forward are
suggesting suggesting that because of
what
somebody and because of their role in
society that you cannot challenge them
that is what you have said this evening
and that is dangerous it doesn't matter
who who put back RAC it doesn't matter
who it is I tell you who's put back
racism people who cry wolf about racism
I don't know if they're C they're
despicable I've been assured assured who
by who never you mind oh come on you're
not going to your sources and but I've
been assured the
your your I don't reveal any sources
right but I've
beened what you're saying more
importantly where is the evidence in the
letters no doubt where in the letters no
doubt letters I would what letters I
would like to see these letters because
no that's where the evidence you ask
where the evidence is I suggest now we
now we may have started something where
we I don't want to wait a thousand years
I don't want them to be locked away in
some cell somewhere I think you're going
to ACC me to the royal family of racism
you should have the decency and the
courage to stand up say who it was say
what they said and you about decy say
when they said it I I I'm flabbergasted
so you're the victim of racism but
you're challenging the victim on having
decency on being decent is that what
you're saying because I know incredibly
who's the victim incredibly difficult
who the vitim I don't know but I do know
you're talking about mythical victim do
know is ridiculous conversation Harry
and Megan so I'm apparently I'm
apparently disrespecting some victim but
you don't know who that is you're you're
challenging what they're saying it's not
true you're Challen how do you know
where's the proof two and a half years
so so what we're waiting for is evidence
and then once you've got your evidence
will you apologize
racist once you've got your evidence
will you apologize yeah you apologize to
don't get me wrong you apologize to mega
mega marle produces actual evidence of
racism let's see it and if if it's
proven that King Charles or the Princess
of Wales were racist about her a baby I
will apologize to her let me tell you I
can said up with real confidence because
it ain't going to
happen welcome back to my 12 ding-dongs
at Christmas where we've been counted
down the best of the bares and bust up
we've had an uncentered in 2023 and
we've reached the top glittering spots
there could only be one number one on
this list we haven't shied away from
covering the Israel Hamas war from both
sides it's often got very heated but we
invited Muhammad hijab and Rabbi schm
onto the show even I didn't know quite
what we were getting ourselves
into is peace possible okay uh not on
this basis right but we've got to try
and get to pece so we get a minute each
again uh Muhammad you'll go first uh
this time so you get a minute from now
Justice is a prerequisite for peace in
South Africa when the aparte system
which we know for a fact Israel is an
aparte State because it has laws like
the right of return which only only only
allow Jewish people to come into the
country and if they convert by the way
to Christianity or to Jew to Islam they
are stripped from that right which is it
meets completely the definition of a
party that's P Corell law school and
according to the UN convention 1973 the
first thing is is when Israel withdrew
in 2005 almost 20 years ago um if Hamas
had not come to power if they had taken
all the international Aid that they got
um tens of billions of dollars peace
would have been achieved by building
businesses
entrepreneur okay we get there now by
destroying Hamas making sure that
there's Democratic elections let the
Palestinian people not
mamed you both agree hamash should be
gone right we can agree on this right
agre that there should be a bigger
Palestinian Authority with armies
and
the way we have in the history of the
world no two Democratic Rockets two
State solution I well you
know I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell I'll tell you if if if two-state
solution is a Hamas State wanting to
eviscerate Israel he doesn't believe in
it but he doesn't believe in a two
solution he believes in a Final Solution
that's what really scares me you don't
believe in a two solution you believe in
a final solution the way you speak about
Jews do you believe in a two that second
state is
Mexico if that second state is is is
Gaza then of course not because it'll
just become another genocidal enemy
wanting to wipe Israel off the map
that's pretty unequivocal he doesn't
really want a two-state solution I don't
want a two-state solution that's a
that's that's a terrorist state to
destroy is personally believe this whole
question should be left to the
Palestinians of what kind of solution
they want however having said that this
man is written in his book a war in
Israel that is the settle I write a book
called The Warrior it's called the the
Israel Warrior something thank you
thanks for plugging fantastic I
appreciate fantastic thank you very much
in that book he writes that the issue of
excuse me the issue of settlements that
me and you both condemn peers I do yeah
yeah yeah we do he doesn't condemn it
because he sees a an ancient biblical
reason to be in that whole land I think
is I think Arabs in Israeli should be
able to live wherever they want I want
Arabs to live in Jerusalem I want Arabs
to live in T I want Jews to live there I
don't believe in the is I don't believe
in Arab I am so proud that Israel has
1.8 million Arab Muslim citizens who are
protected by the ID he calls the IDF a
terrorist
what you should be less proud of is the
rapid expansion of these settlements on
the West Bank it has been
incredibly it's been in my view illegal
it's been declared
illegal many things I'll there are many
things I'll defend Israel about that is
indefensive let me answer let me answer
if you go to places in Jude and samarra
in the West Bank why you call like
because those are the Biblical land who
cares why do you call something Arabia
it's the Arab
you don't know history it was always
your day in Samar the West Bank is the
West Bank of a river we don't call
the with no democracy me come to afraid
to criticize ja yes my friend muhamad go
ahead M conversation you're wearing my
favorite blue color of course I'll let
you speak fantastic for that reason
brilliant thank just because uh I'm
wearing the blue my mother loved that
color and she
pass I thought it would have been
because of Israel because you oh that's
right you wor the Israeli
today can we shake hands no please I
don't want to cuz your hands are shaking
your hands are sh sorry I mean look how
it's peaceful shake my hands no I shake
hands with you you wouldn't shake my
hand after what you said today about me
I can't shake your hand I tell you who
once the absolute annihilation of every
Jew they can get hands on all the Hamas
terrorists who crossed the border on
October 7th who gleefully recorded it
boasted and the Hamas offic wait a
minute and the Hamas official spokesman
only last week said they want to do it
again and again and again if you don't
think are wedded as an organization to
the annihilation of Jewish people you
are living in their Charter in their
Charter it says that they will
murder that I agree with hold on let me
tell you I agree or disagree both the
IDF and Hamas on paper say they don't
want the annihilation of Muslims and
J say that's not I'm not Charter says
explicitly that every Jew will be
murdered byas they are a
genocidal lying you are lying sorry it's
nobody can hear either of you you will
not interrupt me you will not interrupt
me you will not bully me you will not Dr
me I am not afraid of stop saying now
let me bear let me be clear you sh over
each other well then let then you need
to control your guest with all due
respect contr he said equal time and
there's no equal time tell you if you
bring two people on to a debate and
you're saying that we let you
audience
bring when you bring very successful man
and you will and you allow I'll be quiet
man one one one to bring up don't give
him lesson stuff that is so just
embarrassing like sex people's sex
lives not no I did not I no I'm proud of
my books on sex but this is a debate
about I don't care about your sex lives
either of you if you enjoy these 12
ding-dongs of Christmas and you'll love
the PE morg centered YouTube channel
where there's loads more great content
but the fastest growing News and Views
channel in the world right now so become
a subscriber today and we'll be back
with all new ding-dong debates in the
new year until then Merry Christmas and
remember keep it
[Music]
unsensed